قال منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي انه يجري
احراز تقدم في المحادثات بشان التصل
لاتفاق لاطلاق سراح الرهائن وهدنه طويله
الامد في غزه واضاف كيربي في تصريحات قبل
قليل ان الولايات المتحده ترى فرصه لوقف
طويل للقتال في غزه يسمح باخراج الرهائن
واضاف ان العمل الذي انجز بناه وان مستش
شار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سوليفان
التقى بمسؤولين قطريين لبحث ملف الرهائن
المحتجزين في غزه وعبر عن رغبه البيت
الابيض في رؤيه دوله فلسطينيه وهناك
الكثير من العمل الذي يتعين القيام به
للوصول
لذلك معنا من واشنطن مراسله الجزيره وجد
وقفي وجد ما اهم ما جاء عيسان كيربي
تحديدا فيما يتعلق بهذه
الصفقه نعم يعني عبد القادر مستشار الرئيس
الامريكي جيك سوليفان بحسب ما قال كيربي
التقى اليوم رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
لمناقشه الجهود المشتركه من اجل ابرام هذه
الصفقه جون كيربي اكد بان هذه الصفقه ما
تزال تسير المفاوضات باج تسير بالاتجاه
الصحيح وبان هناك تقدم تم احرازه في
الاونه الاخيره على هذه الصفقه هذهه
التصريحات لكيري كانت اجابته ردا على سؤال
بشان تصريحات نتنياهو التي قال فيها اليوم
انه يرفض اطلاق سراح الاف من وصفهم بال
الارهابيين ضمن صفقه تبادل اسر كيربي قال
ان انه لن يرد على تصريحات علنيه لنتنياهو
ولكن التصريحات ما بين المسؤولين
الامريكيين
والاسرائيليين تفيد بان هناك تقدم بالفعل
تم احرازه على صعيد ابرام هذه الصفقه بحسب
ما قال كيربي الامس امس واليوم في ان هذه
الصفقه تتضمن هدى او وقفا مؤقتا لاطلاق
النار كافيا بحيث يكون كافيا لاطلاق سراح
عدد كبير من المحتجزين وفق جون كيربي طبعا
كانت هناك تسريبات عن احتمال ان تكون مده
هذه الهدنه شهران لا نعلم مده هذه الهدنه
ولكن بحسب البيت الابيض هنا فانهم يريدون
لهذه الهدنه او وقف اطلاق النار المؤقت ان
يكون كافيا بحيث يتم
اخراج المحتجزين البيت الابيض يرغب باخراج
جميع المحتجزين في غزه حاليا جيك سوليفان
مستشار رئيس الامن القومي بعد لقائه برئيس
وزراء برئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري
من المقرر ارض ايضا اليوم ان يلتقي
بعائلات المحتجزين الامريكيين واضح بان
لديه معلومات جديده يريد ان يرسلها
لعائلات المحتجزين الامريكيين داخل غزه
ولكن المؤكد بان كل التصريحات الصادره عن
واشنطن هيي فيها تفا الحذر ازاء تحقيق هذه
الصفقه عبد القادر وجد وقفي من البيت
الابيض شكرا جزيلا
لك